Hey guys.
Hi.
Hi Melissa!
Did you dye your hair?  You look so pretty.
Oh, no I didn't.  Thank you though.
I like your romper.  That's cute.
Oh thank you.
Oh, Steve, I gotta talk to you.
Okay, so I guess she's like being nice to you now.
She's been talking so much shit about you behind your back.
Seriously?
Yeah.
All right boys.  Looks like we've got a Frenemy.
Phil, do we have any backstory on the target?
Uh, yeah they actually went to High School together so we got tons of gossip.
Give me something nasty.
Well this is good.  She fell down at a school assembly in front of a group of boys.
Hit the ground so hard she farted.
Lets use it.
*ding ding*
Shit talk complete.
Great.  Mitch, do we have any eyes on the BF (boyfriend)?
Ok we've got him sipping a Lacroix with his bro.  Should we approach?
Abso-fuckin-lutely.
You're more like--
Hey James.
Oh hey Melissa.
Hey.
You look big.
Have you been working out?
Uh yeah.  I mean, a little.
Well it's working.
Out.
Are you sure she should be doing this?
Yeah I heard James is horrible in bed.
We're not actually going to sleep with him you idiot.
We're just stirring the pot.
Well maybe we should talk to her, you know.  Clear the air.
What did you say?
Clear the air.
This is war Mitch.  We're not--...
actually that might not be a bad idea.
I never said anything bad about you.  You're one of my best friends.
I know.  You're one of my best friends too.
And actually I was trying to avoid drama and not tell you this but
Courtney is actually the one who has been talking shit.
*laughing*
Buckle up boys.  We're not going home yet.
Hey guys, I hope you enjoyed that command center sketch.
It was a fun one and we have about I think like one or two more in the works for you so yay!
Just a quick heads up--these are my upcoming shows.  I hope to see you if you are in California.
Especially this one.  It's going to be great.  It's me and 3 of my favorite Asian female comics
and of course a white guy for diversity
so you'll see Brad as well.
My parents are going to be there and I have a lot of jokes that they've never heard so
I'm like kind of nervous so we shall see.
And on that note I do want to say thank you so much to JCPenney.
A few weeks ago I flew out to New York to take part in one of their campaigns and I got to model
on the streets of New York and get my make-up done
all for a great cause.  JCPenney is promoting women who are empowering their communities
and their environments and I was on as someone who is an advocate for suicide prevention.
So you can check out the LookBook.  I'll put a link below
and of course all of these fabulous outfits are on JCPenney's website.
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.